what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to a video that goes
through the differences between the blue
pill the red pill and the purple pill i
guess i was watching a different video
and i didn't even know there was more
than one like pill so
i'm just trying to explore what it means
by alpha male strategies
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel
and let me know in the comments what
video i should do next
and most importantly bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be in
gonna be notified for my daily videos
what's up fellas so today we're here to
talk about the three pills all right
the blue peel the purple peel and the
red peel
all right now so first i'm going to talk
about the blue pill
and the reason i want to talk about
these pills guys because a lot of guys
don't understand what the content comes
from
a lot of the content comes from these
three pills all right
these three dynamics pretty much just uh
explains the whole male population all
right guys
so the blue pill guys is the classic
beta male
all right and what i mean beta male
they're totally naive
all right they don't know female nature
i they haven't been
exposed to it all right so a lot of you
young guys
who just started following my content
and a lot of stuff i tell you you just
fail
you don't want to believe it all right
because you haven't lived life long
enough to experience it
all right this is my one disagreement
with like the
manosphere community is
i hate the argument that if i don't see
things the same way as you do or
i don't agree with you that
somehow
it's because i'm naive like that that's
such a bad argument either it is or it
isn't it's not just be
like just because someone just disagrees
with you doesn't mean they're not eating
all right
that's the bottom [ __ ] line guys so
what you got right here guys
with the uh the beta male the blue pill
guy is
he's totally naive he hasn't experienced
it and so he doesn't know anything he
doesn't understand it yet he hasn't
been exposed to it yet that's your
classic
blue pill guy and one thing about the
blue pill guy with the
one benefit of being a blue pill guy is
they're not jealous
all right the reason they don't get
jealous is because they don't know
female nature they don't know women step
out from time to time when i say that i
think a lot of you guys think i'm
talking about a woman steps out every
[ __ ] day a woman might just step
out on you once a year all right or once
every [ __ ] two years or whatever the
case may be
maybe she does step out on you every day
but i'm just saying hypothetically
uh a woman will step out but she ain't
gonna step out on you every [ __ ] day
all right she'll step out on you
periodically it might be once a year
once every two years
but she will step out on you all right
guys the blue
so like based on his logic
every single marriage the woman steps
out like that doesn't make sense like
some women do some don't people are
people you know guy
doesn't get jealous because he doesn't
know that he doesn't know women step out
all right
so that's the one benefit of being a
blue pill guy you just naive you just
don't know [ __ ] all right you just
haven't experienced it yet
all right the purple pill guy's a little
bit more of a complex guy
all right because here's the thing with
the purple pill guy
he knows female nature all right he
knows it
and this is the thing with the purple
peel guy he knows female nature
but he needs a relationship all right
so that comes a problem all right so
that's why you're gonna see a purple
peel guy
he's the very jealous insecure guy all
right
anytime you see a guy that's in a
relationship that's very jealous
that's because he knows female nature
but he needs a
relationship so he's in a little bit of
a conundrum because he knows it
like a lot of you guys who follow me and
stuff like this right here okay
if you ever decide to get back in a
relationship you will be a purple pill
guy
but you'll never trust that [ __ ] you
would never trust her
all right it's because you know female
nature you know she'll step out on you
all right another thing about the purple
pill guy is
he just assembled female nature for what
it [ __ ] is
all right and what i mean by that guys
is he knows that
if he loses his [ __ ] job or something
like that he knows
she's on the first thing smoking up out
of there he just accepts it
all right and you know that's kind of
sad
but that's that's the reality with a lot
of purple pill guys i don't know if you
guys ever seen these memes
of jay-z with beyonce and stuff like
this and they be at the [ __ ] game and
[ __ ] like this
and you'll see him on the meme and
she'll be texting his phone and he'll be
doing like this looking out to conan's
eye her text like this right here
looking
that's because he's a purple peel guy
all right he's in a relationship he
needs the intimacy of a woman he needs a
comma
but he also cheated on her commitment of
a woman
but he don't trust him all right and if
you ask jay-z
man the man hey man you know if the feds
came and took everything you got
if the feds came and took all your money
your homes your car
left you bankrupt and 20 million in debt
do you think
beyonce would stand by your side i
guarantee you man-to-man he'll tell you
no i don't think so
all right that's the bottom line with
any purple pill man
is that they never trust a woman and
they know that
if they ever fell into hard times that
the woman will be on the first thing
smoking they know that they just
accept it all right and
last but not least guys is the red pill
guy now
the red pill guy is a guy that's
single and just date because he
understands female nature
and usually the red pill i think is a
good phrase of the red
it's interesting because the
manosphere community really looks at
like
their world like they just really feel
like they see the world as how it is
like they are the ultimate truth
um i mean i understand what they're
saying like clearly women
tend to go for guys with money but like
the
issue that they're gonna have is that
obviously the women
that marry their husbands for money are
going to leave when the money goes
and a lot of especially like the rich
guys that you see with models that's
why they went for them pill is the red
pill guy
um usually gonna come across as bitter
all right
so if a lot of you guys watch my videos
or something like this you'll see women
in the comments on the video saying and
i'd like to say that i don't
disagree with everything on the red pill
i'm not anti-red pill i've just noticed
that people that have 100 bought into
the red pill
really truly believe that their way of
seeing the world is just the way it is
anyone that doesn't agree with me isn't
naive
i think that's a bad argument sorry sue
me this dude sounds better this dude
sounds better
is not that i'm bitter at women
i'm really bitter at my reality and what
my reality is
is either be single and
stay single and just date which means
that i'll never have love in my life
or go back to being a purple pill guy
in just a self-female nature for the way
it [ __ ] is
and knowing that she'll leave me if i
lost my resources all right so that's
why when you
run across red pill guys that's why we
typically gonna sound
bitter it's because we know what choices
we have we know we have either those two
choices
stay single and never find love never
never love a woman you know there's only
one way she can't love you
you can only love her either accept that
what or oh that's
interesting so that's why they think
that women
can't actually love you because
they don't oh my gosh because what do
they say they say
men like women that are fit feminine and
friendly
but i wonder if they'd have that same
sorry so they think that men like women
that are fit feminine friendly
you know this is i don't i think that
kevin samuel says that the same idea
and then he thinks that women only like
like him for like resources status
whatever but if the
resources went away the women would go
but at the same time like wouldn't they
say male nature
is that if the women got out of shape
the man would be able to go
right anyways let me know in the
comments go back
which which would reiterate the fact
that like they really don't
aren't in like love them for them if
they would go if they
got out of shape get in a relationship
and just accept that if you look if you
fell on hard times
she's gonna be on the first thing
smoking that's the hardest that's why
when you run across a true red pill man
that's why they sound so [ __ ] bitter
all right now but then i could be better
too and be like if i gained 50 pounds
see ya whatever and plus also aren't
men more likely to leave their wim the
woman
if the woman's sick then men
like aren't men more likely to leave the
woman if she gets cancer than women are
to leave the man if he gets cancer
and isn't that like the ultimate your
resources are gonna go
here's the thing with this guys you know
i want you guys better at women or
whatever case maybe if you're gonna be
bitter or anything
be better at mother nature all right but
if you really
understand human human uh
evolution you would know that nature
has has installed this [ __ ] in women for
a reason
all right the world cannot survive
without women being hardwired to be that
way
all right it's simply listen guys
listen if women aren't hardwired to be
about resources
well essentially what you have is you
have a lot of men who have no motivation
to be successful i know that [ __ ] sounds
crazy as [ __ ] hell
but if women just loved
i would agree with that i didn't they
say that monogamy was part of the reason
that the united states thrived so much
because men were more
like would work harder for their
families all for just premieres
demand as an individual i don't even
know how long the world will survive
i'm just being honest with you i really
don't know how long the world will
survive
women are built to survive all right so
they tend to be selfish
and they're hardwired the way mother
nature has hardwired them to be their
way
to keep human evolution going all right
so that men provide the resources for
the offspring like i told you guys it's
not for the woman
like when you when you typically watch
tv and stuff like this you think the
woman won't resource it so she can go
out and buy a bunch of hermes bags and
gucci bags and just that another
women are hardwired and some of them do
but women are hardwired to want a man
with resources
so her offspring have a better chance of
survival
all right that's what it comes down to
women are hardwired now
the thing is they're still hardwired
from generations when
people badly could eat and [ __ ] like
this right here the case may be
but it's still going to carry over to
the day all right women are hard wired
to want a man with resources all right
and women are hardwired to leave you if
you follow hard times
because it's for the betterment of the
kids it's for the betterment
of the offspring even if you ain't got
no [ __ ] kids
all right women are hard wired to just
think
like that all right it's just the way it
is guys so you know i don't want you
guys better at women
just you know if you're gonna be better
anything be better in mother nature
because
it has what made has hardwired women to
be
like that all right and the purple pill
guy never trusts a woman because
he knows women are evolutionary
hardwired
to want to replicate the alpha male all
right
which is going to be me guy which is
when i when i say the alpha male is
going to be somebody like me six foot
four six foot five
broad shoulders good looking guy it's
going to be somebody like me that's just
that's just the way it [ __ ] it ain't
got to be just they could be a 5
7 guy that's a [ __ ] alpha male
whatever the case may be but the women
are
hardwired to want to replicate the
[ __ ] alpha male just the way it is
guys
and that's the they just all the people
in the mannose fear
it irritates me because they just call
themselves alpha males
and a lot of them come off douchey to me
and i'm not even trying to be
disrespectful at all but like
i'm just not a big fan of like the
douchey
vibe it's just not for me she wants to
have a baby by the alpha male
back in the day with the kings and [ __ ]
like they're still today the king will
have a thousand [ __ ] women they all
trying to have
kids by the [ __ ] king it's just the
[ __ ] way it is guys
and so you know we red pill guys we
stuck with a conundrum
do we just want to date for the rest of
our [ __ ] lives
or do we go back purple pill and just
accept
female nature for the way it is she's
going to leave me if i lost everything
and she's probably going to step out
from time to time but you have to
realize that a lot of
things are in like
nature but to act like women
are automatically going to step out from
time to time there are people
that like nuns people that don't ever
have sex again they're people that wait
till they're married there are people
that do it it's not easy and i know not
everyone actually does it
like the majority don't but your human
nature
makes you want to do a lot of things it
doesn't mean you have to do it all right
as a purple peel guy you would never
trust a woman
you because you know female nature and
you know she
can't love you so you know any purple
pill guy knows if i lose my job she's
out of here
every purple peel guy knows that all
right which is kind of a sad reality all
right
so your choice is your i'm gonna be red
pill probably you know whatever case may
be
if i ran into a girl that just blew me
away made a million dollars or whatever
the case may be or whatever case may be
in the future some
who knows i doubt it but like most guys
no matter how you know who you is or how
alpha male you as right now most guys at
some point
enter into a beta male enter back into a
beta male stage
even if you just accept female nature
you just enter back into a beta mess i
wonder if that's why they literally call
everyone a beta male
like that's the one thing i've noticed
in this community
is they call everyone a beta
like they call 85 percent of men beta
so i'd be interested to hear more about
what he means by the stage to where
everything just gets old
some guys don't do george clooney i
think they're getting married till he's
like 55.
up to that point he had been a bachelor
all his [ __ ] life all right so most
guys at some point
they just accept it and just want to
settle down and start a family whatever
the case may be all right
all right and also i want to talk to you
guys about how to handle
losses all right well here's the thing
with losses guys seen a guy put this in
the comment section of the video and
it's a good
guys all losses are it's just failures
with monetary loss that's all it is and
so guys
all losses is is the same thing as
failures it's a learning experience
unfortunately when you go out and you do
things in the real world or whatever the
case may be and you make a
you make a mistake or failure or
something you don't lose [ __ ] it's just
a loss of time
and you know a learning experience in
business
if you make a mistake you're going to
lose money all right i'll give y'all a
case in point
my live stream yesterday i had the tv on
behind me
youtube uh they didn't give me a strike
but
uh i they demonetized the video because
they pulled up the video as a [ __ ] uh
movie and they
did the filter picked that [ __ ] up even
though it's behind me
even though it was on [ __ ] mute the
filter still put that picked that [ __ ]
up and demonetized the video
now youtube demonetizes like half my
videos it's so
let's hypothetically say that video make
me
fifty dollars a month over a course of a
year so over the course of year i just
lost six hundred dollars
off of that one live stream being lost
so that's 600
a month just from that mistake y'all
guys see that i ain't bitching
complaining about it or none of that
i'ma just take it as a learning
experience to make sure that going
forward
no music is playing in the background no
tvs are playing y'all guys have seen me
play
this tv here been on a bunch of times
now this is the bedroom tv that was the
living room tv
but y'all have seen this tv on a bunch
of times and luckily nothing has ever
been flagged
all right so i'm lucky in that aspect
but it's a learning experience just
because the tv's on mute another like
this
if they pick it up they can give me a
copyright uh and demonetize the video
they didn't give me a copyright strike
strike on them but they demonetized the
video that's costing me money that was a
mistake it was a big mistake
but i'm just going to accept it as a
learning experience and move on i know
going forward not to do no [ __ ] like
that again to make sure that i [ __ ]
got nothing playing in the background
nobody playing music next though
because youtube pick every [ __ ] thing
up all right so that's how you got to
look at losses guys it's a reason why
when you run a business guy guys they
don't
charge you no taxes the first they get
you exempt from taxes
uh the first year of your business or
whatever case may be all right uh
just uh state taxes you ask them for
because they know you're gonna make
mistakes
all right they know you're gonna [ __ ] up
and make mistakes and they know you
probably gonna be in the [ __ ] red
from [ __ ] making mistakes i had
bought a car back home from a guy who
had a deals license back home alabama's
years ago
it took me [ __ ] six months to get my
[ __ ] title because the dude had just
started doing it he
know how to go through all the paperwork
and [ __ ] to get the [ __ ] title
it took us six months of paper of him
trying to figure this [ __ ] out
just for me to get my title to my car
all right he rambles a lot like some of
his videos could really be
put down to like 10 minutes just because
he it was his first time starting
business he was fresh out
so he was still learning all right so
guys if you
if you're in business guys you gonna
make mistakes you gonna take losses
don't fret on it that's how you [ __ ]
learn i you know
what i'm getting is a lot of you guys
don't wanna make mistakes this is the
number one reason why guys
people don't start businesses a fear of
loss all right you gonna take losses
i've taken losses i i've taken a a bunch
of losses
and figuring [ __ ] out just mistakes is
only gonna make me better in the future
guys
yeah this is a a really important
mentality that i learned from my dad
because my dad's a really successful
entrepreneur
i would always get caught between like
which decision do i make
and my dad would just tell me make a
decision
and deal with the consequences just make
a decision because
i would just be so indecisive and he's
right like
it's because i'd be afraid of losing
money or losing something i've wasted a
ton of money
on a lot of a lot of stuff i didn't use
but
it is what it is you just gotta keep so
do not be afraid of loss you gonna lose
money
i wish it was like you know some things
in life where you just make a mistake
and you just learn from it as a learning
experience
in business you learn for run with it at
your [ __ ] pocket
all right i'm gonna tell you something
about that too guys it makes it stick a
lot harder
all right i guarantee you won't see no
tv playing because it affects my pocket
all right sometimes you make mistakes
and you end up making that same mistake
again and again
when some fake your pocket you don't
make that mistake no more you learn from
it all right
and so sometimes taking losses can be
the best learning experience because
when some hit your [ __ ] pocket oh you
don't make that mistake listen
one time i didn't understand what a sign
said up here in new york they got all
these confusing ass signs
and so i parked somewhere while i was
supposed to park and i didn't understand
the sign
that ticket was like 150 dollars lesson
learned i know don't do that [ __ ] no mo
and what i mean by that not just with
that sign if it's any sign
and i don't know what the [ __ ] it mean
just go to a parking garage
if it's a sign and i'm not 100 sure
don't say well i think it i think it
means
no [ __ ] that all right 150 dollar ticket
or pay a 20 for a parking garage all
right easy got them so if it's something
i don't it was an expensive lesson but i
learned from it all right guys
so take losses as learning experiences
all right
but getting back to these pills guys uh
yeah the blue pill guy is going to be
the guy that's totally naive
and some guys quite frankly guys they go
through that they hold [ __ ] life all
right some guys
you know they they don't watch the [ __ ]
on youtube or they just not experienced
it they haven't seen it
and so they just naive and this would be
the god his wife would come home with
some
some round of [ __ ] mouth and he'd be
like hey babe you got something around
your mouth right though
and then she like oh i was eating a
mayonnaise sandwich earlier
he just he just totally naive he don't
know nothing he's just totally clueless
to what's the [ __ ] going on
the purple pill guy is probably the
worst out the guys is because
this is the [ __ ] that's gonna be
jealous this is the [ __ ] that
checks his woman
our phone check her [ __ ] purse always
calling wanna know what she had it's
because he purple pill
because he knows female nature crazy
i would say he knows how women are
but yet he needs a relationship he needs
that intimacy with a woman
all right and so he's never going to
trust the woman the blue pill guy
oh yeah i'm going to be at my friend's
house the whole weekend or whatever the
case may be i'm going to help her do
some decorating this is the blue pill
guy he don't know no better oh okay all
right tell susan i said hello him the
purple pill guy this is not true look at
i i have a friend who she's engaged now
she's been with her boyfriend for five
years
i used to go to like out with her to
bars
like super late whatever he would
describe her fiance
as a what do you say the purple
whatever the beta naive one probably but
i was with her the entire time and she
never did anything
i was even remotely cheating like she
would never do that
and a lot of times because the woman
that they've dealt with and the way
that they see the world has been
negative they just assume that's how
everyone
is and i'm not naive like i know that
people do that i know that cheating
happens but
like it's all about how you see the
world honestly uh
yeah i'm going over susan house for a
couple hours we're gonna have a couple
drinks when you getting back
because he knows he knows he's probably
gonna be stepping out with a dude
he knows all right and so this is the
thing guys understand that if you do go
to
being a purple pill guy you're gonna
always be [ __ ] paranoid all right
just the bottom [ __ ] line
the red pill guys are the guys that
gonna seem like they come across as
bitter
but it's really not built at women it's
just better at what they reality is
i know what my reality is i have either
two choices in life
either accept female nature uh for the
way it is and go back purple pill
or stay single in dating for the rest of
my life it's kind of a sad
kind of two sad choices if you act well
it's the way that he looks at the world
again um if you see the world through
that lens that's all you're going to see
and that's something that i think the
manosphere community really discounts
like um
it's kind of like if you see if i was
like
under like the feminism lens if i only
saw myself as oppressed and like only
saw myself as going through all these
challenges as a woman like
men are bad da da da da i'm gonna see it
everywhere and it's the same thing
but let me know in the comments i'm sure
you guys are going to disagree with me
on that so let me know in the comments
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring the notification
bell